[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
more strikes and more jurors seated in
the trial of derek shovin
how a minnesota court is selecting a
jury for the first former officer to go
to trial
in the murder of george floyd will the
three other ex-cops charge in the george
floyd case
testify against derek chauvin and why a
mixed martial arts fighter's testimony
could be key
our legal analysis plus the case sparked
protests globally
but in wisconsin unrest ended in the
fatal shooting of two in kenosha
when will kyle rinhaus stand trial law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
members of the jury for the murder trial
of derek chovin are being selected
in a slow and methodical process angela
levy is in minneapolis and is here to
explain what questions they're being
asked
in the death of george floyd
yeah brian this is certainly a tedious
process but it's actually
moving along quite slowly the jurors are
questioned maybe for
about an hour a piece now so far five
members of the jury have been selected
three are white men one is an
african-american man
and the fifth is a woman of color
if you and i were to meet in some social
situation what would a couple of things
you want me to walk away knowing about
you
you expressed a somewhat unfavorable
view of the group
blue lives matter just a couple of the
questions posed to prospective jurors
who could end up on the final jury that
decides the fate of derrick chauvin
attorneys ask some questions based on
answers from juror questionnaires
when you first received your
jury notice what was your initial
reaction i was super excited
excited yeah that's actually why i voted
so i was really surprised when i
heard got back feedback right away i was
really yeah i was really excited i
didn't know what it was i didn't care
what it was i was just excited to be
summoned she made it on despite having a
relative who is a police officer
awesome she said she could be impartial
when judging what happened the day
george floyd died in police custody
another juror said he had seen parts of
the videos of george floyd being
arrested
he also has a wedding coming up that the
trial could possibly derail
i know that you can't speak for your
fiance
but in the event that this trial
did last past may 1st how
significant of a hardship would that be
for you um
i mean it would be obviously
disappointing you know
we would obviously liked for this to
occur
as normal there's no word on how his
fiancee feels about that
but there were other questions about the
man's beliefs
there are some people who have decided
to
not watch nfl football anymore as
sort of a protest to players who would
take a knee during the national anthem
are you aware of that
uh sure yes what are what are your
thoughts about that uh my thoughts is
the players can do whatever they'd like
to
at times that juror seemed
pro-prosecution and then pro-defense
in the end he made it on the jury
despite that may 1st wedding date
go ahead and throw me under the bus with
your fiance okay i will do that
now initially we were told by judge
cahill his court said
that they would be selecting of course
the 12 jurors but then
up to four alternates that has now
changed the court said there will now
only be two alternates selected
instead of four ryan thanks angenet
two alternates seems far too little
especially in the middle of a pandemic
but we'll see how that plays out
joining us today to break down the jury
selection and derrick children's trial
is new york city public defender marva
brown and terry austin
marvel let's jump right into it you've
picked jurors before
what do you think the focus will be here
and is two alternates too few
yes as a defense attorney i want
uh jurors that are pro law enforcement
they've got friends and family members
that are
police officers in the military i want
people who are going to respect the
police on my jury
and then just having two alternates i
don't think that's enough
given we're in a pandemic if anyone gets
exposed to covet they'll have to
quarantine
and they might lose jurors in over the
duration of a trial
so i think that the judge needs more
alternates than two
yeah and if it goes below 12 that's
grounds for a mistrial we got to do this
all over again terry the judge announced
in court that the state supreme court
denied the defense's petition
so where does that leave the murder in
the third degree charge
this means brian that the issue is going
to go back
to judge cahill in trial court remember
the appellate court
said that judge cahill erred when he
failed to reinstate
the third degree so he really has no
choice at this point
but to reinstate that charge and this is
a huge
victory for the prosecution because it
gives them the ability to have a jury
consider
more than the second degree murder in
the second degree manslaughter now they
consider
whether or not he acted with a depraved
mind which is the third degree so it's a
big victory
for the prosecution makes sense and
jeannette the lawyers during jury
selection
seem to have different styles and it
makes sense you want to be liked you
want to be
understood nelson seems to be more
approachable than the prosecution
who has an army of lawyers but how do
you think it's playing out between the
two
uh sides during jury selection
yeah i mean i think eric nelson seems
like maybe more
you know like the regular guy of the the
two prosecutors doing the voir dear
steve schleicher is the
assistant attorney general a special
assistant attorney general working pro
bono on this case he's handling the
voidier
for the prosecution but they have very
different personalities you can kind of
tell
i mean steve schlecker seems like kind
of a guy you could have a fun
conversation with but eric nelson seems
kind of more like a guy you'd run into
you know at a party or a bar and maybe
like more kind of
a chatty guy matthew frank also kind of
a funny guy he's on the prosecution team
an assistant attorney general
he kind of made some funny comments this
morning so
definitely different personalities at
play in this trial
and then all all ways out where is the
jury going to gravitate towards what
side what's lawyer
we'll see how it plays out thank you
still ahead on law and crime daily
delays in the trial of the kenosha
shooter
when the pre-trial hearing and trial are
set to begin when we come back
but first who can testify and to what
the motions argued by the lawyers in the
trial of derek chovin to decide what
jurors will hear
in the alleged murder of george floyd
[Music]
next
welcome back 4x cops are charged in the
murder of george floyd
but derek sherman is standing trial
first and on his own it now appears the
other 3x officers
will not testify against him derek
showing is facing two charges
second degree unintentional murder and
second degree manslaughter
two tao thomas lane and jay alexander
king
are charged with aiding and abetting
second-degree murder they're scheduled
to go to trial
in august body worn camera video of all
four ex-officers
from the incident will come into
shobin's trial but
the defense is hoping to keep out
statements made by the four defendants
once the investigation into their
conduct officially began
mr chauvin is brought to room 100 of the
city hall which is the standard practice
in critical incidents here in
minneapolis and is
afforded an opportunity to consult with
a lawyer at that time
the lawyer who responded they didn't
make a statement and i believe
ultimately we are in agreement that
there would be no reference to the
invocation of the fifth amendment rights
at that point
beyond officers tawan lane gave tape
recorded voluntary statements to the bca
and in connection with the fbi
counseled by attorneys that's
testimonial evidence that i would not
have the ability to cross-examine those
other witnesses
i confirmed with each of the attorneys
last night that they are not permitting
their
clients to testify in this trial i would
have no ability to cross-examine
those particular statements anything
else again
i think it's fair game one of the
witnesses who will testify is a
bystander named donald williams
who was a trained mixed martial artist
fighter and saw
george floyd die the defense will no
doubt
as their experts have opined alleged
that the bystanders
were an unruly mob and that mr
williams is one of the most vocal
members of that unruly mob
this unruly mob that consisted of some
teenage girls
a nine-year-old an elderly gentleman who
was trying to help
and mr williams who was quite vocal sir
williams will explain
that that a blood choke is where you do
that you try to interfere with the blood
flow to render that person unconscious
and he recognized aspects of that and
what mr chauvin was doing at the scene
mr williams will also testify to what he
calls a shimmy
and it's a it's a move that mixed
martial arts
athletes are trained to do just to
tighten
that choke hold mr williams will point
out for the jurors
at trial where it can be seen that mr
chauvin is
rocking back and forth to secure that
hold
to secure mr floyd to the ground because
he does say and it is audible on
the video that the terms
blood choke i think he is entitled to
say what his experience is
and to explain what he meant by that
and also the shimmy to be honest
here to break down these motions are new
york city public defender marvel brown
and terry austin
terry we're seeing the sides fight a
little over the rulings
is it too early to see one side winning
or
maybe losing based on the arguments you
know i think so far both sides are
making
many many motions in lemonade and i
think one of the biggest motions is
whether or not
these prior bad acts can come in if they
come in i think it's bad for children
because it shows
that he is using these techniques and
he's used it before and it's
unreasonable
the other big motion is the medical
examiner the defenses actually
said that they want to preclude
testimony
about the medical exam unless it is
with the state's medical exam the the
hennepin county medical examiner
so i think hopefully the judge is going
to do the right thing there
and allow both medical examiners to come
in because we know that there was an
independent
in me and i think it would be fair for
the jury to see both of those
now marvel when i first saw the george
floyd video and heard
an individual talking about chokeholds i
said if that person is able to testify
as to what they know and they have
experience
it's going to be damning for the defense
now we find out he's a mixed martial
artist and has 10 years of experience
how's that going to affect this case i
think he's going to be a very strong
witness for the prosecution because not
only is he
an eyewitness he's also an expert
witness because of his experience with
mixed martial arts
and he's going to be able to explain to
the jury
how those blood choke holds are done uh
what the process is why you do it and
it's really going to
chauvin's intent in this case and he's
shouting
warning chauvin you're killing him and
he kept applying the pressure so that's
going to be devastating for the defense
yeah
eyewitness blood choke holes shimmy
these are things to definitely pay
attention to in the trial because
they're going to have a great effect
on the outcome coming up on law and
crime daily what is derek sherwin's past
as a police officer
and how can that affect his future in
criminal and civil cases
plus the agreement to delay the trial of
kyle rennhaus
when will it start and what lawyers are
saying needs to be done
before the trial can begin next
[Music]
the trial of a man accused of killing
two people and wounding a third during
protests
last summer in kenosha wisconsin has
been delayed
kyle rinhaus is facing charges of double
homicide and attempted homicide
his trial date was scheduled for march
29th but both sides agreed
they need more time to prepare
prosecutors cited outstanding issues
such as dna testing
the trial is now scheduled to begin on
november 1st rainhouse is out of jail on
2 million
bond he's due back in court for a
pre-trial hearing on may 17th
here to discuss the latest in the
kenosha shooting cases public defender
marvel brown
and co-host terry austin terry trial
delayed to november 1st giving both
sides time to prep
what do you make of the need to review
dna this doesn't sound like a dna case
well you know brian to a certain extent
every criminal case
is a dna case they probably want to test
the dna on the gun
but if you think about it they've had a
year now and they could have done that
they did
also give other excuses so they said for
instance that
they wanted to make sure they could line
up witnesses and they wanted to make
sure
that the schedule of the attorneys would
work out
but i honestly think they are just
trying to get more time
to prepare for the case and remember
rittenhouse
is not in jail so he can wait as long as
he wants to oh yeah no rush when your
client is out marva may 17th is the date
for pre-trial hearings
what type of arguments do you think
either side could be making at such a
hearing
i think they're going to say they're not
ready again there are
extensive amounts of videos that the
defense are going to have to review for
suppression
they don't want written houses
statements to come in and so they're
going to say judge we need more time to
review these videos his statements his
mother's statement
um there's no property at issue in this
case we know it's his gun
so it's not about the property being
suppressed but they might have to comb
through his social media and say don't
allow the social media in
so i think it'll be another delay yeah
it's definitely a lot of information
they've got to comb through social media
video emotions eliminate what can and
cannot be heard in a trial
think george floyd then apply that to
kyle right now it's probably similar
situation
thank you both when we come back the
world knows derek chovin as the ex-cop
who kneeled on george floyd's neck
but who is the man behind the badge we
dive into that question when we come
back
welcome back as ex-minneapolis police
officer derek showman stands trial for
the murder of george floyd
many are wondering who the defendant is
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross
digs into chauvin's background thanks
brian coming up this week on brian ross
investigates
a look at the record of brutality
complaints against derek chauvin
he's the officer accused in the murder
of george floyd
no wonder so many people recognized him
when that video was seen
around the world i texted my sister and
said to my sister i think that's the guy
that shot me indeed it was
tolls had been shot seven years earlier
by officer chauvin
as he and other officers responded to a
domestic dispute
all i know is he kicked down my front
door i ran into the bathroom he kicked
in the bathroom door
i stood up and then he just started
hitting me after he started hitting me
i got shot and he tried to walk me
through the apartment
and i couldn't walk anymore he later
claimed you were trying to go
for his gun yeah yeah
i read that when i was i did a couple
days in jail because they dropped the
charges
but um yeah found out that uh
he said that i tried to take his gun
from him
was that true hell no no
no and tols was far from the only person
to recognize officer chauvin in the
video
i saw him i said i think that's derek
chauvin oh no
but then i heard somebody in the video
shout out a badge number
michelle gross is the founder and
president of the minneapolis group
called
community action against police
brutality she was not surprised to see
derek chauvin using
a long band technique to hold george
floyd on the ground
well it wasn't a surprise because i knew
of him because he was a bad actor for a
long time
he has been a problem officer for a very
long time and so his name was well known
to us
and minneapolis police department
records show officer chauvin was the
subject of at least
18 complaints involving police brutality
along with other internal investigations
in all but a few cases
no action was taken against him it said
to me
that um all the times that people had
complained about his conduct
and that he had been given a free pass
this was the culmination of that
ira tolls never filed a formal complaint
against chauvin
after he was shot by him and toes has
since learned that chauvin was given
the department's medal of valor for his
handling of the incident
are you angry about all this i'm very
angry
i'm very angry i'm angry at the whole
system
um and angry
that he didn't have to announce himself
uh give me any commands
tell me any tell me to get on the ground
uh
he just started hitting me and then shot
me that's what i'm mad about i'm mad
that he's able to do
that and get away with it and then
get a promotion or get a award
tolls who has since been convicted of at
least two felonies
involving domestic abuse says the
initial incident with chauvin
led him down a bad path
for you what will be justice in this
case i'm a god-fearing man i believe in
forgiveness and stuff like that but
also believe in accountability
everything i did in my life i had to
be accountable for so he has to be
accountable for it also
that's this week on brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network brian
thanks brian back one last time to talk
about derek shovin's background is marva
brown and terry austin
marva so we know this information our
viewers know this information about
derek chovin
but will the jury hear about it too
i don't think so brian unless children
testifies the only way the prosecution
is going to be able to get this
these prior bad acts in is
if they show his motive and intent on
their direct case
and i don't think they have that if
chauvin testifies on his own defense
then they can impeach him with these
prior bad acts as a defense attorney
i'd have my clients say i'm a great cop
i'm wonderful i've never had a problem
and then the prosecution will be able to
impeach real quick
um marva do you think derek chovin will
take the stand
in this type of case no
and he definitely should not i don't
think the defense attorneys would have
him testify because
it wouldn't end up well for him these 18
complaints coming in against him would
be devastating to the defense
yeah as we called it that would be
opening the door for the prosecution to
just
bring a mack truck down of all these
prior complaints
terry the civil rights case is likely
one of what they call
patterns in practice for chauvin could
what we learn about strovin's history
have any impact on the civil rights case
well brian you know the two cases
obviously are being tried
separately but it could have an impact
theoretically
the information from one could be
introduced into the other
the family actually sued both
minneapolis and the four
former police officers and they claimed
that the officers
violated floyd's constitutional rights
during the actual arrest
but they're also saying that the city
harbored a police culture
and it was filled with racism and
excessive force so i do believe that
pattern and practice will be
an issue in the civil case so we'll see
what happens
when the case is tried ultimately but
you know i think that the
evidence will show that ultimately there
was a pattern here
both with children and with the city of
minneapolis because i think
other police officers have had similar
backgrounds and
similar records and the city failed to
take action as related to all of those
police officers
so is it kind of like saying that the
city or maybe the minneapolis police
department is on trial
so to speak in the civil rights case
because they allowed derek chovin to
continue to do this is that what
you're saying terry that's exactly what
i'm saying they saw what was happening
they saw that there were these repeated
offenses and
instead of holding the individual
officers accountable
either by firing them or disciplining
them or retraining them
they allowed all of this to happen and i
think they could be held live
makes sense be sure to check out the law
and crime network for gallaudet coverage
of derek shobhan's trial
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you